comment faire courir en pleine rue des
chinois parisien est ce que vous êtes au
courant que en chine internet c'est
censuré
non
je vous crois pas
est ce que vous êtes au courant qu'il ya
de la censure sur internet chinois
on peut bien rigolé cinq minutes mais
leur méfiance est légitime de pékin à
paris qui la censure sur le net c'est
tabou et il ya de quoi 40000
cyberpoliciers employés par l'état
chinois contrôlent les internautes et sa
24 heures sur 24
dernière tentative de cette surveillance
accrue fouiller les boîtes mails de
dissidents chinois le géant du web
google a fini par voir rouge il a menacé
de fermer son portail internet en chine
un exemple parmi d'autres sur le google
chinois aucune trace des trois mille
étudiants morts de tiananmen sur le
google classique en revanche on n'a pas
de mal à trouver des images des chars de
la répression chinoise du dc on pourrait
appeler ça du négationnisme nous avons
retrouvé cai chongguo un des héros de ce
printemps étudiants réfugiés à vincennes
depuis 20 ans lui n'a pas oublié
les schémas aujourd'hui sont pratiqués
schiller imaginez tout ça tangue lessard
c'est pour cela arriver
ils sont froment
et de marist sent presque exception
admiration il faut qu'on se prend pour
le problème en chine
la patience est indispensable
aujourd'hui qui milite avec des ong pour
défendre le droit des travailleurs
chinois il risque la prison s'il revient
dans son pays la basse ou blogs son nom
ses écrits ont été censuré pendant 20
ans le gouvernement chinois surveille de
très près les cybermilitants 69 d'entre
eux croupissent en ce moment en prison
ça c'est une vidéo qui a été tournée par
un amateur et qui a été mise en ligne
sur youtube
pierre haski ancien correspondant de
libé à pékin et fondateur de rue89 un
journal sur internet reçoit
régulièrement des infos inédites envoyés
par des blogueurs chinois
comme ces images de manifestations qui
ont fait chez nous font la une des jt
c'est des phénomènes qui était
impensable quand je suis parti comme
correspondant en chine c'était un an
dans l'été 2000 et juste avant mon
départ il y avait à la une du financial
times une information sur une émeute qui
s'était déroulé dans le nord de la chine
un mois plus tôt aujourd'hui mais dans
la dans la demi-heure vous avez les
images sur youtube et vous pouvez suivre
quasiment en direct les événements à
travers la chine
pour surfer sans crainte plus de 17
millions d'internautes chinois utilisent
désormais des proxys ce sont des
logiciels très performants qui
permettent de naviguer anonyme en
fringues 20 ans informaticien paris
connaît bien le problème il fabrique des
reportages faits maison pour une radio
pirate que l'on trouve sur le net et qui
aimait clandestinement vers la chine
son audience ferait pâlir les plus
grands médias français 30 millions de
chinois dans le monde sont allés
cueillir
la une aujourd'hui c'est pour parler de
remise du prix sakharov à le parlement
européenne hier à strasbourg un prix en
faveur des droits de l'homme qui n'a pas
bonne presse en chine en 2008 il avait
été attribué à un militant en dépit des
pressions exercées par pékin mais si
règne informe les chinois sur ce qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit de savoir il prend
parfois à linverse ces infos en chine en
appelant ses proches au bout du fil
cette fois sa cousine
ouais ouais
elle va lui expliquer pourquoi la série
weeds ou vient d'être censuré en chine
cette série très populaire raconte le
quotidien a priori banale d'une fille à
shanghai le conflit centrale c'est la
main le logement il parle plutôt
une une fille qui habite à shanghai
depuis déjà 10 ans mais il est là
toujours n arrive toujours pas acheté un
logement à bas par là le moyen normal
ccm voiture
ce que n'ose pas dire règne c'est que la
série a été censuré en chine parce
qu'elle aborde de front les problèmes de
promotion canapé
dans certains épisodes on apprend que
pour mieux se loger là bas il faut
savoir coucher
mais les sujets politiques ne sont pas
les seules cibles des autorités il y a
aussi la pornographie
il vante de retour de shanghai où il a
vécu quatre ans ramène à son ami
luthiers restaurateurs à bastille les
dernières news chinoise pornographiques
le buzz du moment sur la toile des
photos très perso d'un célèbre
réalisateur chinois en bonne compagnie
ellison chaîne est un vecteur en combi
on s'est connus en chine et là je crois
que c'est la crise aussi très connu
appréciez donc ça a beaucoup choqué les
chinois at il a pas voulu il n'a pas
voulu les réponses internet c'est
antoine réparer son ordinateur que le
réparateur a vu
sur internet team hrc c'était brad pitt
et angélina jolie was a vu d'ici ça peut
faire sourire là-bas le réalisateur qui
n'y est pourtant pour rien dans la
diffusion de ces photos a fini en prison
la morale sur le net imposé par les
autorités les internautes chinois savent
aussi la contourner walchi comme par
exemple avec ce clip de l'ama chanteur
qui circulent sur le net en apparence
les paroles de la chanson sont anodines
grâce à des erreurs d'accent subliminal
ça peut tout aussi bien vouloir dire ça
comme ça
[Musique]
cette fois au moins les censeurs chinois
n'ont pas mis les gentils la mort en
prison quand à l'auteur du clip il a
réussi à rester anonyme par guy mathot
dit